the warning
this song
and then get struck
and when it is over nothing is left a
tsunami the word in Japanese means
harbour wave Japan has been hit by many
tsunamis in its history as a result of
its location it lies across the edges of
four tectonic plates where most
earthquakes the principal cause of
tsunamis are when two tectonic plates
push together the resulting earthquake
sends an enormous burst of energy up
through the ocean displacing enormous
quantities of water a series of waves
expands in all directions in deep water
these waves travel fast up to five
hundred miles an hour but only reach a
height of a few feet a passing ship
might not even notice but as the waves
enter shallow waters friction with the
ocean floor lowers the wave speed and
raises their height until it landfall
they can engulf
story unlike ordinary waves a tsunami
wave doesn't crest and break instead it
advances like a wall of water that
crashes over the coastline and
everything in its way reaching even as
far in the mind more damage is caused
when the wave recedes dragging
everything in it back
and most tsunamis have multiple waves
each arriving anywhere from ten to sixty
minutes after the first strike just when
survivors think the danger is over the
deadliest tsunami ever reported occurred
in December of 2004
an earthquake off the coast of Indonesia
triggered a tsunami that surged across
the Indian Ocean and reached as far as
the Costa
all sections of cities from the storm
more than 200,000 people died
most had no way of being worn
5,000 miles away the Pacific Tsunami
Warning Center in Honolulu is on call 24
hours a day to prevent a similar tragedy
from happening in the United States
scientists monitor tremors and quakes
from around the globe if a quake big
enough to cause a tsunami occurs it is
their job to alert the coastlines in the
tsunamis path the advice is simple move
to higher ground wait for news of the
tsunami has passed and be ready to deal
with the ruins left in its way
you